-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're talking to
Taylor Schilling.
and last time you were here,
it was promoting a horror film
"Prodigy," and you were
saying that you wanted to --
-Was I?
-I think it was the last time.
It was like February.
Like, not this February,
the one before.
-I'm excited about that,
but, frankly, I'm really
distracted by this plant.
-Are you having regret about i
or do you feel like
it's stealing your focus?
-I was, like, actually thinkin
like, "Should we put books?"
But every time I see someone
doing a Zoom interview,
I judge their entire life by
what books are on display.
-And would you say,
on the whole,
you're more impressed
by a person
or less impressed by a perso
after you see their books?
-Boy, that's a toss-up. 50/50.
-Yeah.
-But how many people
do you think we're seeing
their actual bookshelf
and how many people
do think have curated it
knowing they're gonna be on TV
-I would say
we're seeing probably
2% of people's real books.
-Yeah, I think so, too.
I think we're --
-Don't you think?
I think everybody spent
a lot of time thinking about
what other people
will think of their books.
-Yeah.
-I'm really glad that
we're acknowledging this,
because that's one of my -
that's really what
I think of when I
see these Zoom interviews.
-Where I don't think anyone --
I don't think anyone's watchin
this right now saying like
"That's not Taylor's plant."
-I know.
I don't think so either.
-I think it's very obvious
that that was there,
even if it weren't
on TV tonight.
-"She's had that plant since
high school."
-What's that?
-Yeah.
No. "She's had that plant
since high school."
That's what I think about
some of these books.
"You read that
in 10th grade, friend."
-And, by the way, thank you,
Tank, for sticking around.
Although, she doesn't --
That's what I like about Tank.
She, like, knows when
she should be on camera
and when she shouldn't.
-She's really -- right now
I'm sorry.
We don't have to --
She's supposed to go away.
Do you want to talk
about the show?
-I do.
So, this is a horror --
-I don't mean to just go
completely --
-No, look, I get it.
You're always about the plug
Everybody says that
about Taylor --
"She's always about the plug."
-That's what they say.
-ABP -- Always be plugging
You --
-This shirt is
really something, isn't it
-It's really good and it's
really holding it's shape.
I think when we first saw it
we were like --
-That's what
I'm impressed by, too,
with all this, like,
dog wrestling.
-It's is -- It's like --
The two things that are --
just remain perky throughout
this whole interview
are the shoulders of that shir
and Tank's ears.
-I know.
She's really here for it.
-It's really nice, because
I feel like if they were -
You know, 'cause I feel like
she's remained interested in m
throughout this
entire interview.
-She sure is. She's fascinated
She's -- Yeah,
she's, in fact, drooling.
I wasn't gonna mention that.
I don't know what's going on
I don't know if, like,
a dog expert will tell me
that that's a sign of something.
Maybe she just needs dinner.
-Yeah, well, maybe -- Do you
ever -- Is that a case of --
Let me just, like,
try to game this out.
Maybe every morning,
you watch my show
while you're feeding her,
and so now she's actually
having a Pavlovian respons
to hearing my voice.
She's like, "Is it time fo
breakfast again?"
-That was a good process of --
That was good deduction.
-Yeah.
-Sherlocky.
That's Seth Sherlock.
That was good.
Maybe this is happening.
-This is -- Come on.
Ugh. But to the show. I get it
I know you're frustrated.
-Ugh!
-So, this is a horror anthology,
but it's --
-Whoo!
-It's not?
-No, it is, it is.
-Oh, good.
-I'm just celebrating with you
-Oh, great.
-Whoo!
Yeah.
-I don't want to
give anything away,
because, obviously,
the clip doesn't quite show us
where we're going.
But there's a fair amount of
makeup involved in this.
Was that an
entertaining part of that?
-Let me tell you.
There was a fair amount
of makeup involved,
and I had to do something
that I was excited for,
because, you know, in, like,
a "Transformers" movie
or, like, an "Avengers" movie,
you know,
there's a lot of makeup
on one's face,
and I was excited
to experiment with that.
But I learned in this --
I learned on this job, Seth,
that I have panic attacks when's
there silicone on my face.
-Oh, wow.
-So I had to tap out, yeah
I was about to put
a whole mask on,
and it was a big day of makeup
And then I laid back
in the chair
and I started to ask if
they could make the nosehole
bigger and the eyeholes bigger
And then the visual-effects gu
was just like, "You know what?
I'm gonna call this.
You need to leave.
I'm not gonna finish
putting makeup on you face."
-How far into the process?
'Cause I know, sometimes,
that can take hours.
How far into it did you tap out?
-We're like --
We were like 15 minutes.
And I had the rest of the da
off from work
because he wouldn't put it
on my face.
But I thought
that was very charitable.
He kind of was able to
stand up for me
in a way I wasn't necessaril
able to stand up for myself.
-Yeah, I imagine that he,
over the years,
probably has
an expertise in knowing
who can put up with
something and who can't.
-He knew.
[ Dog sneezes ]
[ Laughter ]
-That is --
I think going through COVI
and hearing a sneeze that loud
it's hard not to be
very jarring.
-I know. It's uncomfortable.
-And then you
immediately, like --
You index like,
"Can dogs get COVID?"
-Yeah.
-But God bless you.
-The answer is no.
-God bless you, Tank.
They absolutely can't get COVID.
And, also,
I can't put on those things.
I can't put makeup
like that on my face.
If there was anything
I learned from "Monsterland,
it's that I cannot have silicone
over my noseholes or my eyes
I can't do it.
Also, I was trying to pain
my nails before we started
and I didn't have time.
I wanted to make sure I wa
completely unchipped for you
Seth, it's so nice to see you.
-It's so nice to see you, too.
And I think that was reall
great that you did that,
'cause I feel like we were gonna
hear a lot on social media
after this interview about how
chipped your nails were,
and now I feel like
you've covered your back.
-I know.
I mean, I feel like I really -
I did it the best I could.
Between the narcolepsy and
the state of public discours
in our country,
I put on a shirt.
-Yeah. I think you did great
I mean, I do think there
are gonna be some people
that are a
little bit disappointed
you didn't nod out
in the middle of this.
-Yeah.
Someday, you'll see the pictur
I'm talking about.
-Yeah, we'll do that.
I think the off air is probabl
the better way to do that.
-Yeah.
-Congratulations on the show
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
You're doing such a great job.
I love what you do right now
It's beautiful. It's wonderful
-And we'll see you soon.